und jetzt das heute journal bettina
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in einen schon die flugroute
des bundeskanzlers zeigt wie verzwickt
die lage ist olaf scholz flog heute nach
kiew dann wieder zurück um morgen in die
gleiche richtung zu fliegen nur eben
weiter bis moskau es soll offenbar nicht
so aussehen als käme der kanzler als
abgesandter der ukraine zum russischen
präsidenten der deutsche kanzler in
heikler mission es gibt stimmen die
sagen scholz vermittlungsversuch könnte
die letzte chance sein um einen krieg
abzuwenden heute in kiew bleibt der
kanzler bei seiner strategie aus zwei
teilen ernsthafter dialog ja sollte
russland aber beim nachbarn
einmarschieren dann zitat wissen wir was
zu tun ist axel sturm berichtet wenn man
wollte und genau hinsah und hinhörte
konnte man viel entdecken an diesem tag
bei diesem antrittbesuch unter pandemie
bedingungen bitte nochmal händeschütteln
noch einmal ja in ordnung für mich ist
das okay die hand zu reichen
scholz bei selensky alles sehr förmlich
antrittsbesuch als bundeskanzler
anstands besuch als neuer freund
kurzbesuch heute in kiew morgen in
moskau aber zuerst hier in kiew ganz
bewusst die themen die gefahrenlage an
der grenze die verhandlungslage mit
russland die gesamtlage viele themen für
einen kurzbesuch
wir sind uns einig in der großen sorge
wird die derzeitige lage an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze wir
erwarten deshalb von russland eindeutige
schritte zur deeskalation der
gegenwärtigen spannung für die
bundesregierung ist klar dass eine
weitere militärische aggression gegen
die ukraine schwerwiegende politische
wirtschaftliche und geostrategische
konsequenzen für russland zur folge
trotz oder wegen der solidarischen worte
präsident selensky schrieb viel mit und
hatte fragen die der kanzler nicht alle
beantwortete
ich selbst habe keine antwort auf die
frage bekommen welche sanktionen gegen
die russische föderation zwecks die
eskalation abgestimmt worden sind ich
habe diese frage dem kanzler und anderen
staats und regierungschefs in den
vergangenen wochen mehrfach gestellt
es war ein frühlingstag in kiew das
konnte man auch sehen und auch dass
trotz der malerischen stimmung die
schweren themen nicht fern blieben
fragen nach waffen aus deutschland nach
nord stream 2 nach der nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine die frage von
mitgliedschaften
wissen steht der praktisch gar nicht an
ein kleines signal in richtung moskau
selensky jedenfalls notierte wieder und
dürfte nicht zufrieden gewesen sein der
kanzler aber versprach dann noch geld
150 millionen euro aus einem laufenden
kredit ein neunstelliger
stimmungsaufheller könnte man sagen auch
in moskau konnte man heute viel
entdecken die wichtigkeit von langen
tischen beispielsweise tische fast bis
zum horizont präsident putin inszeniert
sich und seine minister bei gesprächen
an schier endlos langen tafeln
sitze ich höre ihnen zuerst dem
verteidigungs dann dem außenminister
strategiegespräche so scheint es
brauchen einfach fläche
gibt es ihrer meinung nach noch eine
chance mit unseren partnern eine
einigung über wichtige themen zu
erzielen themen die uns sorge bereiten
oder ist es nur ein versuch uns in
endlose verhandlungen zu ziehen ein
prozess ohne logische schlussfolgerung
und lavrov antwortet seinem präsidenten
als chef des außenministeriums muss ich
sagen das ist immer eine chance gibt
wie gesagt wenn man genau hinhört und
hinsah gab es viel zu entdecken
was geht vor am langen tisch und dem
kopf des wladimir putin das ist die
milliarden rubel frage wir werden sie
heute nicht klären was aber hilft in
jedem konflikt sich die sache mal von
allen seiten aus anzusehen und zu gucken
was stimmt was stimmt nicht russland
argumentiert die eigene sicherheit
stünde auf dem spiel der westen habe das
land betrogen die nato weist das
vehement zurück bevor sich also ganz
eigene formen von geschichtsschreibung
breit machen lohnt es sich mal zurück zu
schauen wie sind wir eigentlich dahin
gekommen wo wir heute sind am rande des
abgrunds in sachen ukraine christian
roos und ein heute-journal überblick
[Musik]
der konflikt zwischen russland und dem
westen wurzelt in den jahren nach der
wiedervereinigung
die nato habe damals versprochen sich
nicht weiter nach osten an die grenzen
russlands auszudehnen behauptet russland
heute dennoch schließen sich polen
ungarn tschechien rumänien bulgarien und
auch die baltischen staaten sukzessive
der nato an russland bezeichnet das
heute als verrat aber das war nicht
immer so im gegenteil in mehreren
verträgen hat moskau den osteuropäern
zugesagt ihr bündnis frei wählen zu
dürfen
1990 etwa in der charta von paris oder
später noch einmal in der nato russland
grund akte
dann 2008 billig die nato georgien eine
langfristige beitrittsperspektive zu
aber die haltung russlands hat sich
geändert im august sollen russische
panzer über die grenze nach georgien
nach einem blitzkrieg erkennt moskau die
unabhängigkeit der gebiete südossetien
und abchasien an georgien verliert 20
prozent seines staatsgebietes
ende 2013 beginnt der konflikt mit der
ukraine nach der pro europäischen
revolution und den gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzungen auf dem majdan
annektiert russland die krim angeblich
um die russischsprachige bevölkerung vor
mord und gewalt zu schützen
der konflikt verlagert sich in den osten
der ukraine in die gebiete luhansk und
donetsk dort erobern separatisten die
macht unterstützt von russland der
westen beschließt wirtschaftssanktionen
sie werden nach dem abschuss von flug lh
17 über der ost ukraine verschärft
seit 2005 zehn versuchen deutschland und
frankreich zwischen der ukraine und
russland zu vermitteln die gespräche im
sogenannten normandie format sind aber
festgefahren bis heute hat der konflikt
mehr als 13.000 tote gefordert
professor sönke neitzel von der uni
potsdam ist der derzeit einzige
professor für militärgeschichte in
deutschland herr professor schön dass
sie bei uns in guten abend schön guten
abend des ios kann es lehren aus der
geschichte geben wie wir in die aktuelle
lage wie wir die aktuelle lage in den
griff bekommen na ja die geschichte
internationaler konflikte offenbar schon
die logik wie solche konflikte ablaufen
und das können wir schon länger nur sind
eben keine blaupausen wir können also
nicht eins zu eins
konflikte von 1438 die
lösungsmöglichkeit den verlauf auf heute
übertragen also die logik die
grundsätzlichen logischen ja das kommt
der lernen aber es ist eben nur eine
blaupause wir müssen letztlich diese
konflikte selber lösen lernen aus der
geschichte ist dann auch wieder begrenzt
und wir wissen immer nicht so sehr in
welches beispiel nehmen wir denn jetzt
seit 14 und 38 andere beispiel also wir
müssen uns schon selber den
herausforderungen stellen dann nehmen
wir doch mal anders der russische
präsident durchaus eine kosten nutzen
abwägungen nicht dass jetzt mal vornimmt
was spricht denn militärisch aus putins
sicht für eine invasion der ukraine und
was dagegen
also dafür spricht dass die nato nicht
eingreifen wird nicht direkt angreifen
wird und es einfach schlicht machen kann
russland ist militärisch überlegen die
kleine ist unterlegen die russen haben
insbesondere fähigkeiten der luftlande
kräfte sie könnten sehr schnell zu
schlagen und das wird eigentlich von
keinem bezweifelt dass es russland
möglich wäre etwa kiew oder den das den
bereich östlich des die ab und zu
besetzen dagegen spricht dass
eigentlich man immer bei einem
militärschlag die überrascht schon auf
der eigenen seite haben denken wir 1900
2014 haben wir ein beitrag gesehen die
krippen die ost ukraine der westen war
völlig überrascht die nato war völlig
überrascht und das ist jetzt nicht der
fall also die scheinwerfer sind hier
angestellt und wird ihn einfach ins
scheinwerferlicht der internationalen
öffentlichkeit treten und sagen ich tue
das was ihr erwartet wofür irgendwo vor
jetzt die amerikaner so war das ist
wieder relativ unwahrscheinlich und es
wird natürlich sanktionen geben also
putin muss abwägen
welchen nutzen er davon hat und mir
erscheint das eher unwahrscheinlich das
problem ist nur es ist eben mein eigenes
rational unser rationaler sie was sie
und ich wir können das vielleicht
überlegen aber es ist eben nicht das
rational von putin dann gucken wir doch
mal weil wir nicht in putins kopf rein
schauen wir können auf das was
unbestreitbare ganz offensichtlich auf
dem tisch liegt über 100.000 soldaten
sind da aufmarschiert das ist ja selbst
für jemanden wie den russischen
präsidenten durchaus eine gewaltige zahl
das sind auch gewaltige kosten für sein
land wie kommt er denn da wieder
gesichtswahrend raus also ich glaub der
kostenfaktor ist wäre für uns im westen
glaube ich an faktor ich glaube nicht
dass es für putin so entscheidend ist
ich glaube dass rational ist ein anderes
ja und das ist auch eine große frage wie
kommt der von der bremer wieder runter
auf die ihr ganz nach oben geklettert
ist er muss ja der eigenen bevölkerung
den eigenen machtapparat ein erfolg
vorweisen nun haben wir keine freie
presse und er kann alles mögliche als
erfolg verkaufen er kann sagen die nato
habe zugesichert dieses und jenes aber
in der tat ist er ganz weit oben und er
hat ja auch ein vertragsentwurf den
westen geschickt den wird die nato
niemals unterschreiben also wir alle
sind ratlos weil er sehr hoch gepokert
hat waren ja von vornherein ein sehr
großes risiko gegangen wir alle sind
ratlos haben sie gesagt der
bundeskanzler muss jetzt aber einen plan
haben in irgendeiner form erfährt ja
morgen nach moskau er hat heute in kiew
gesagt wir sind bereit zitat für einen
sicherheitsdialog herr professor sie
haben die forderungen des kremls gerade
genannt die sind für die nato komplett
inakzeptabel weil sie die gesamte
geschichte europas um 30 jahre
zurückdrehen würden
wie soll denn so ein sicherheitsdialog
dann aussehen naja also die einzige
möglichkeit die man wieder aus unseren
rational sehen könnte wer eine finlandia
sierung der ukraine dass die ukraine
selber anbietet ja wir werden nicht
mitglied der nato aber wir haben die
freiheit uns in unserem
gesellschaftssystem im rechtssystem
richtung westen zu entwickeln sowie
finnland etwa aber wir werden nicht in
die nato eintretender was finnland eben
auch sozusagen versprochen hat ob
angesichts der bedrohung aus russland
kiew dazu bereit ist kann man natürlich
bezweifeln denn scholz kann ja nicht
über die ukraine hinweg dinge anbieten
da kann ja nicht für den ukrainischen
präsidenten sprechen also aber das ist
die einzige lösung dass man sagt einem
eine aufnahme der ukraine steht nicht
zur debatte aber ich glaube nicht dass
die nato dass der westen die amerikaner
und ein schriftstück unterschreiben
werden auf dem steht die ukraine wird
niemals mitglied der nato dass das wird
man nicht tut man nicht putin nicht
geben jetzt gibt es menschen die sagen
schon die tatsache dass wir hier darüber
reden was wir mit ihnen anbieten könnten
das bedeutet in seine falle getappt zu
sein ich erinnere mich da einem gespräch
das ich vor ein paar tagen haben heute
schon mal mit der estnische
ministerpräsidentin geführt habe die hat
genau das gesagt wie sehen sie das
ja ich kann das verstehen aus estnischer
sicht aber ich würde immer argumentieren
auch aus historischer erfahrung
diplomatie hat eine chance und
diplomatie spielte in allen großen
krisen eine rolle und in allen großen
krisen war eigentlich nicht klar am
anfang wie es ausgehen würde also ist
wäre glaube ich töricht wenn der westen
sagen würde nur mit militärische
abschreckung mit wirtschaftlicher
abschreckung agieren würde ich glaube
schon dass die bundesregierung gut daran
tut auch die diplomatische karte zu
ziehen die frage ist überschreiten wir
unsere grenzen wir können nicht über die
interessen der ukraine
entscheiden oder anderer staaten aber
das für diplomatisch verhandeln müssen
dass wir versuchen müssen zusammen zu
kommen wir können ja russland nicht
weggehen von der landkarte also wir
müssen mit diesem faktor einfach umgehen
denn deswegen ist auch das diplomatische
neben anderen faktoren wichtig ganz kurz
noch herr professor nach ihrer
langjährigen erfahrung in dem fachgebiet
was haben sie für ein gefühl für ein
bauchgefühl
klappt das loch bleibt es friedlich oder
gibt es krieg also ich habe in den
letzten tage viel mit hochrangigen
leuten der bundeswehr gesprochen und die
waren relativ cool und das nährt in mir
die hoffnung dass es am mittwoch nicht
zu einem krieg kommen wird sagt
professor sönke neitzel von der uni
potsdam ganz herzlichen dank für das
gespräch sehr gerne
und hanna bleibt beim thema und guckt
auf die baltischen staaten die wir
gerade schon kurz angesprochen hatten
ganz genau konkret auf litauen das jetzt
nämlich verstärkung von der bundeswehr
bekommt 350 deutsche soldatinnen und
soldaten sollen zusätzlich dorthin
verlegt werden heute sind die ersten
truppen am flughafen von kaunas angeht
eingetroffen sie sollen das nato
bataillon the town verstärken das von
der bundeswehr geführt wird neben
truppen schickt deutschland außerdem
fahrzeuge nach litauen darunter sechs
panzerhaubitzen
südlich von münchen sind zwei s bahnen
zusammengestoßen
dabei wurde laut polizei mindestens ein
mensch getötet und 14 personen wurden
verletzt das unglück ereignete sich am
nachmittag auf einem eingleisigen
streckenabschnitt in der nähe des
bahnhofs ebenhausen chef plan warum
beide züge die strecke gleichzeitig
befuhren ist noch unklar und gegenstand
der ermittlungen
der weltklimarat icc hat heute mit den
abschlussberatungen zu seinem neuen
bericht begonnen darin soll es um die
folgen des klimawandels gehen und darum
wie sich die menschen daran anpassen
können regierungs vertreterinnen und
vertreter sowie experten aus knapp 200
ländern sind bei den beratungen dabei in
zwei wochen soll das ergebnis dann
vorgestellt werden
gegen den terrorverdächtigen
bundeswehroffizier frank o a ist erneut
haftbefehl erlassen worden wegen flucht
und verdunklungsgefahr
bei einer kontrolle waren bei ihm
gegenstände gefunden worden die als
beweismittel dienen könnten das teilte
das oberlandesgericht
frankfurt mit bereits seit mai muss sich
frank ua wegen der vorbereitung einer
schweren staatsgefährdenden gewalttat
vor gericht verantworten er soll sich
vor seiner festnahme 2017 als syrischer
flüchtlinge ausgegeben und
terroranschläge geplant haben für diese
sollten dann migranten verantwortlich
gemacht werden
die korona überbrückungshilfen sollen
unternehmen in not unterstützen und das
länger als bisher geplant die
ministerien haben sich auf eine
verlängerung der finanzhilfe bis ende
juni geeinigt eigentlich sollte sie
bereits am 31 märz auslaufen
gleichzeitig geht die zahl der
neuinfektionen seit mehreren tagen
zurück dem robert koch institut wurden
76.000 465 neue fälle gemeldet und auch
die sieben tage inzidenz sinkt weiter
und liegt nun bei
59,8
wir bleiben beim thema in einer reihe
von ländern um uns herum spielt corona
kaum noch eine rolle und das nicht weil
dort die infektionszahlen so niedrig
wären im gegenteil die regierenden dort
haben quasi politisch beschlossen die
gefahr durch das virus sei jetzt zu
managen und zwar ohne große regeln und
beschränkungen
deutschland ist nicht an diesem punkt
die einen sagen zum glück die anderen
fragen warum nicht aber auch für
deutschland soll jetzt ein konkreter
plan kommen an dessen ende die
allermeisten maßnahmen geschichte sein
dürften stichtag zwanzigster märz frank
buchwald hat mehr so schlimm wie
befürchtet ist es nicht gekommen die
krankenhäuser können ihre corona
patienten offenbar gut versorgen von
überlastung jedenfalls ist kaum mehr die
rede damit ist die rechts
rechtfertigungsgrund lage für corona
auflagen nicht länger gegeben auch der
expertenrat der bundesregierung hat
gestern öffnungs schritte gefordert am
mittwoch beraten bund und länder deshalb
wieder mal über corona maßnahmen eine
beschlussvorlage macht in berlin bereits
die runde lockerungen nach einem
stufenplan im einzelhandel soll die 2g
regel wegfallen auch das limit für
private feiern soll deutlich steigen
ab 4 märz könnte dann gelten 3g für
gastronomie und hotels zweig plus für
diskotheken clubs und
großveranstaltungen die dürfen in
innenräumen bis 40 prozent auslastung
gehen höchstens aber 4000 fans im freien
läge diese grenze bei 60 prozent oder
maximal
25.000 menschen zum 20 märz könnten dann
alle tiefgreifenden schutz maßnahmen
wegfallen etwa schließungen oder kontakt
beschränkungen ebenso die home office
pflicht solche öffnungen dringend
geboten sagen manche ministerpräsidenten
einige länder haben bereits begonnen
das ist absolut verantwortbar wir müssen
glaube ich immer wieder neu erklären
dass die hohen inzidenz die es immer
noch gibt das sind halt zahlen die wir
vorher nicht kannten eine ganz ganz
andere bedeutung haben bei unserer hohen
impfquote und angesichts des milden
verlaufs bei omikron die grünen sehen
das ähnlich auch sie plädiert für
lockerungen schritt für schritt und
regional abgestuft wir brauchen einen
gemeinsamen stufen plan der die regional
differenziert aber dabei
bundeseinheitliche kriterien wie
schwellenwerte und instanzen bietet
wichtigste voraussetzung eine hohe
impfquoten auch sie ist regional sehr
unterschiedlich die umstrittene
nebenpflicht in kliniken und
pflegeheimen hat heute die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz beschäftigt
vieles müsse noch geklärt werden räumt
die vorsitzende ein trotzdem gibt sie
sich optimistisch wir haben ja
festgestellt dass schon durch die
ankündigung dass es eine
einrichtung bezogen impfpflicht gibt
selber im land seit zumindest seit
november bis jetzt noch mal unsere
impfquote gerade in den bereichen um
zehn prozent steigern konnten schon
allein die ankündigung hat gewirkt
über eine allgemeine impfpflicht wer
sich dann vielleicht impfen lassen
müsste wann und wie oft darüber berät
der bundestag eine entscheidung könnte
ende märz fallen für eine neue
virusvariante und den nächsten herbst
surfen viele könnte deutschland dann
gerüstet sein ganz sicher aber weiß das
niemand
one million rising eine milliarde
menschen die sich erhebt das soll die
größte bewegung der welt sein und zeigen
wie mächtig frauen sind wenn sie sich
zusammenschließen
jede dritte frau wird in ihrem leben
misshandelt geschlagen vergewaltigt das
ist rund eine milliarde damit sich etwas
ändert an dieser statistik des grauens
haben sie sich heute auf der ganzen welt
versammelt und getanzt so wie hier am
frühen abend in berlin mit choreografin
gegen die gewalt die initiatorin sagt
tanzen ist feierlich und gefährlich
freudig und irritierend es ist die
perfekte protestform nur dass sie in
afghanistan nicht mal tanzen können wer
dort protestiert braucht viel mut und
ist gleichzeitig in großer gefahr katrin
eigendorf ist in kabul
es sind nur noch wenige die sich trauen
öffentlich zu protestieren wir fordern
bildung freiheit und unsere rechte rufen
sie weil afghanische medien nicht wagen
darüber zu berichten filmen sie selbst
mit ihren smartphones wie
taliban-kämpfer sie bedrohen und
beschimpfen
[Musik]
ein [ __ ] wird kommen und 50 von
euch töten schreibt ein kämpfer im
hintergrund
auf ihrem handy sagt zimmer die
aufnahmen der letzten proteste die 26
jährige ist eine der mitbegründerinnen
der bewegung afghanistans starke frauen
sie möchte sich offen vor der kamera
zeigen wenn ihre einzige hoffnung ist
dass ihre proteste weltweit gesehen
werden
unsere nachbarländer die internationale
gemeinschaft und auch die vereinten
nationen dürfen das islamische emirat
nicht als offizielle regierung
anerkennen das ist keine gute regierung
frauen werden ausgeschlossen und mädchen
haben kein recht mehr zu studieren
für ihre proteste nutzen die frauen vor
allem die sozialen medien als netzwerk
aber auch um hilferufe zu senden in
einem video zeigt eine der aktivistinnen
wie taliban kämpfer in ihre wohnung
eindringen ruft um hilfe die aufnahme
wurde tausendfach in sozialen medien
geteilt inzwischen haben die taliban
samaná freigelassen in den straßen von
kabul ist die angst spürbar und jeden
tag werden die einschränkungen schlimmer
frauen laufen kilometerweit zu fuß weil
sie alleine kein taxi nehmen dürfen
alleinstehende mütter können ihre kinder
nicht ernähren weil ihnen nicht erlaubt
ist zu arbeiten die afghanische
frauenrechtlerin tarifa gefahr die im
august nach deutschland geflohen war
nachdem die taliban sie mit dem tod
bedroht hatten fordert europa dürfe
nicht tatenlos zusehen
es ist klar sie sind nicht für ein oder
zwei jahre an der macht sie werden über
jahrzehnte bleiben so bitter das ist es
ist ein fakt wenn sie an der macht
bleiben wollen dann müssen sie die
rechte der frauen und die menschenrechte
achten
bei internationalen verhandlungen wie
zuletzt in oslo versichern die taliban
frauenrechte zu achten ihnen geht es
darum dass die welt ihr regime anerkennt
doch in afghanistan wächst der druck auf
die frauen während eines protestes
filmen aktivistinnen wie taliban-kämpfer
sie angreifen zimmer weiß sie riskiert
ihr leben aber sie will weitermachen
wenn das islamische emirat glaubt wenn
wir eine foltern werden die anderen sich
nicht mehr aus dem haus trauen dann
täuschen sie sich die afghanischen
frauen sind nicht mehr dieselben wie vor
20 jahren sie werden immer weiter auf
die straße gehen und ihre stimme erheben
an einem geheimen ort treffen sich die
frauen um plakate zu malen ihre
botschaften verbreiten sie dann über die
sozialen medien sie müssen vorsichtig
sein
die taliban gehen inzwischen immer
härter gegen aktivistinnen vor und
nehmen frauen fest die angst wächst auch
bei den mutigen
es gibt immer noch tausende menschen in
afghanistan die enge kontakte nach
deutschland haben und immer noch warten
auf eine möglichkeit auszureisen
so nochmal zurück zur situation in der
ukraine die macht nicht nur der politik
große sorgen sondern zunehmend auch der
wirtschaft hanna ja das kann man so
sagen denn auch die investoren schauen
ganz genau richtung russland und ukraine
mit folgen für die börsenkurse der dax
fiel heute zwischenzeitlich deutlich
während der ölpreis kräftig stieg frank
bethmann an der frankfurter börse ist
die gelassenheit der vergangenen wochen
also jetzt endgültig verflogen sieht so
aus die nervosität ist greifbar am
vormittag verlor das aktienbarometer
fast 600 punkte erholte sich zuletzt
aber wieder in der hoffnung dass am ende
doch die diplomatie siegt dennoch bleibt
ein minus von 2% oder über 300 punkten
europaweit heute teilweise deutliche
abschläge an den aktienmärkten unter
druck auch die börse in moskau und der
rubel und die ganz große sorge bei den
anlegern die energiepreise könnten
weiter deutlich anziehen und den
wirtschaftsaufschwung gefährden der
ölpreis am abend bei 96 dollar je fass
und vermutlich schnell über 100 dollar
sollte es tatsächlich zu einer
eskalation kommen denn russlands
bedeutung immens moskau ist der größte
erdgas und der zweitgrößte ölexporteur
der welt auch die weizenpreise steigen
kräftig seit januar bereits nicht gerade
überraschend denn 30 prozent des
globalen weizenhandels bestreiten
russland und die ukraine
der konflikt am schwarzen meer birgt
also nicht nur das risiko steigender öl-
und gaspreise auch nudeln brot und
andere getreideprodukte könnten
demnächst teurer werden vielen dank nach
frankfurt
bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck hat
heute den standort der insolventen mv
werften in wismar besucht und den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern dort
hoffnung gemacht er sagte den mv werften
unterstützung zu und betonte dabei wie
wichtig es sein neue und
klimafreundliche geschäftsfelder zu
erschließen außerdem nannte er die
gründung einer transfergesellschaft als
zentrales ziel sie soll sicherstellen
dass die knapp 2000 mitarbeiter der mv
werften ihren lohn erhalten und das auch
über das insolvenzgeld hinaus der
hollywood regisseur und produzent uwe
reitmann es tut mit familien
blockbustern gelangen ihm vor allem in
den 1980 er und 90 er jahren zahlreiche
kassenschlager einen absoluten superhit
hatte er mit ghostbusters die
geisterjäger die action komödie spielte
weltweit fast 300 millionen dollar ein
und kam auf mehrere fortsetzungen white
men wurde 75 jahre alt
in den usa ist das sportereignis des
jahres der super bowl im american
football gewonnen hat ihn in diesem jahr
das team der los angeles rams in einem
dramatischen finale gegen die cincinnati
bengals vor heimischem publikum gelang
den rems kurz vor schluss der
entscheidende touchdown
am ende hieß es 23 zu 20 für die
footballer aus kalifornien für die rems
ist ist der zweite super bowl erfolg
ich kenne amerikaner für dieses nicht
nur das wichtigste sportereignis des
jahres sondern überhaupt der wichtigste
tag des jahres für uns war es ein sehr
wichtiger montag hier im heute-journal
und gegen 0 uhr 30 meldet sich hier
gundula gause mit unseren breiten
journal update von seilen an sie ein
sehr angenehmer abend
[Musik]
das wird eine sehr windige wetter woche
denn in lockerer folge ziehen die tiefs
von westen heran und das entlang des
caps das ist dieses stark wenn band denn
ungefähr zehn kilometer höhe hier mal
mit diesen orangen pfeilen
gekennzeichnet
in der kommenden nacht ist es noch
vergleichsweise ruhig nordwesten fällt
etwas regen und auch hier in
süddeutschland oberhalb von 800 bis 1000
meter fällt auch schnee es kann glatt
werden auf den straßen zumindest im
süden denn hier in bayern sinken die
werte auf plus 2 bis minus 1 grad sonst
bleibt die nacht etwas milder divis
temperaturen morgen liegen im westlichen
dem südlichen bayern sowie vier bis
sechs grad sonst werden 7 bis 10 grad
erreicht und auch morgen vor allen
dingen am vormittag fällt noch regen
oder schnee hier im süden es wird zum
teil aber auch ganz freundlich zwischen
der ostseeküste und dem sauerland im
nordwesten aber werden die wolken
dichter werdender beginnt es dann
spätestens am nachmittag zu regnen und
der wind nimmt dann schon durch zu das
ist zunächst ein südwestwind und
mittwoch kommt dann der erste sturm
herren das sehen sie hier über den
britischen inseln über dem land wird der
wind etwas schwächer über der nordsee
nimmt er dann wieder kräftig zu dieses
ist die situation
donnerstagmittag da droht also strom bei
uns an der küste und nicht nur dort es
gibt also viel regen am mittwoch den
sturm am donnerstag und am freitag
könnte es sogar für einen orkan reichen
vorher aber wird es noch mal sehr mild
da steigen die werte bis 17 grad guten
abend